I could see them getting engaged this
year you can this year yeah I hope for
her a little Sagittarius yes I hope she
finds true love wedding bells on the
horizon for Hill Swift well it wouldn't
be the first proposal prediction Patti
Stanger has gotten right I said the same
thing to Lady gaga
I said you're gonna get engaged too and
a month later she got engaged and we
look a body language and matchmaking the
way they're holding their instinct they
just like they look like their walk
alike they talk alike it wasn't that way
with Calvin how old do you date
I'll go late 20s in too late for you at
47 years old
okay next she's returning to help new
rich and stubborn singles July 8th on
me-tv Patti on the time so we made a
date at art a cafe with a million dollar
matchmaker who told us she's taking her
signature tough love approach to another
level
I'm totally baffled as to why I'm single
I wanted to heal people who were the
toughest cases that could not find love
that were stuck in their own ruts I have
to break you so that I could build you
right back up you make them cry yeah so
kind of like you have to find they gotta
get to Jesus before they figure out
what's wrong with him you're
loosey-goosey with your body I want to
like okay I want to cuddle you can't be
held if you leave and throw all the
other lonely fish in the sea this
modern-day Cupid's revealing her top
tips for finding love online you're just
judging on a picture right you're
judging in a picture which you don't
even know if it's real and that has
happened first up talk about what you
really want what you're looking for
don't be nasty about it three apps is
really good but you know if you can
afford to do five and you're gonna let
it down I'm go for it
always weaving puppet place what's your
biggest nono I had just a recently where
a guy tried to come and get me you know
at his house he wanted me to go to his
house so he wasn't taking no for an
answer
I'm not a fan of that now in case you're
wondering
patty herself has never been married so
guys if you're interested she tells us
that she's actually on the dating app
bumble